Speaker 1: Let's try Bert from Jersey. Bert,
are you able to get right into your question?
Speaker 6: Yes, I am. Hear me?
Speaker 1: Okay, David. I hear you.
Speaker 3: Fine. Okay.
Speaker 6: Thank you for taking. Here's
my question. You know, you hear a lot of Trumpers
and Trump people, you know, they talk about his
accomplishments to the country is move in the
right direction. You know, all these subjective
things that's hard to deny. I don't understand is
if you look at Trump's fiscal record, right? Yep.
We are 8 trillion more in debt from him from
the beginning when he started to where he is
today. Right. He's supposed to be this financial
genius. He's supposed to be the businessman. And
yet he added more debt in four years and any U.S.
president ever in the history of time, period.
Like, there's a lot of criticism of Trump and,
you know, Stormy Daniels know list goes on. You
never hear any criticism of his financial record.
So why is that? I mean, where is it? Well, so.
Speaker 1: You're saying economically.
Speaker 6: Economically. Right. We are 8
trillion poorer after Trump than before him.
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, most people
don't even understand the difference between the
debt and deficit and are confused about reducing
the deficit versus reducing the debt. And so
it's honestly ignorance is a big reason why this
conversation isn't had more. You say to someone,
hey, Biden reduced the deficit and then they go,
No, but the debt has continued to increase.
Right. Biden slowed down the rate at which
the debt is increasing. You've lost people. So a
lot of this, quite frankly, with that particular
issue is people don't know what's going on. They
don't understand it. And I've tried so many times
to explain the difference, but I do think there
are easier metrics to look at stock market,
GDP, job creation, unemployment,
inflation, consumer confidence,
etc.. And on average, all of those do better under
Democratic president. So I tend to focus their.
Speaker 6: The thing is is there there big
accomplishment is that, oh, financially we
were the economy was booming. Everyone was doing
great. No, we're not. We're as a result of his
policies and him and are cutting taxes and
increasing spending. We're 8 trillion poorer.
Speaker 1: The debt is higher, without
a doubt. But I concede that there were
many economic indicators that were
strong under Trump. Under Trump,
I just don't think it had anything to do with
the Trump being president, if that makes sense.
Speaker 6: But I guess he doesn't. You
never hear people criticize about this.
Speaker 1: You don't? No, you're right. And like
I said, I think a lot of people don't don't even
understand the difference between the deficit. I
got I apologize. Let's keep it to one thing today,
because I'm up against the clock and I got to run.
Okay. Thank you. All right. There we go. It's a
good question. We should be talking more about
that. People don't even get it. So you're sort
of like trying to tread water with people that
are trying to pull you under. It's sad situation.
Let's go to a break. We will take calls again. And
I apologize. I wasn't able to get to everybody.